[ Cheers and applause ]
-Kim, it's --
it's so fun having you here.
-Aw, Aidy,
I'm having so much fun, too.
-I mean, your life
seems so exciting,
like jets and sisters
and an underpants company.
Oh, Kim, are -- are you crying?
-A little.
I'm just so busy all the time.
I just want
one normal, boring day,
kind of like the day
you have every day.
-Ouch. But it's true.
I-I mean, I kind of wish
we could just switch places.
-Well...
I do have this magic clock.
-Wait a minute. You want to use
this clock's dark magic
to switch places for 24 hours
without anyone knowing?
Okay, bitch.
[ Thunder crashes ]
[ Energy crackling ]
-Ticktock one and ticktock two.
You are me and I am you...
for one day.
♪♪
[ Camera shutters clicking ]
-Ooh!
-Kim, who are you wearing?!
-Um, a bunch of clothes.
-Are you ready
to take the bar exam?!
-Wait. What?
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, Aidy.
-Yes, I'm Aidy.
-I was thinking,
in the office sketch,
we're gonna have you play
Paula Deen,
and you'll do
a little racist dance.
Uh, do you like that?
-Yeah.
Seems like I would say yes.
[ Camera shutter clicking ]
-Yes.
Oh! You're looking great, Kim.
Do you have a few more in you?
-Yeah.
Maybe get the whole body.
-Hey, yesterday, did she have
that massive bush?
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-All -- All men want
a piece of ass.
Natural sex.
♪♪
-Medical grade sunscreen.
Oh, it's like chowder.
[ Cellphone chimes ]
-Hey, guys,
I just wanted to show you
that I'm wearing, like,
a little brown bra,
and, um, it feels really cool,
really different
than my usual very firm girdle.
So, yeah,
I think I pretty much decided
I'm gonna stay like this
forever.
Like, I'm not gonna do, like,
the clock stuff again, ever.
[ Line rings ]
-Hi.
I'm trying to reach
Kim Kardashian.
It's urgent.
-Okay.
Can I ask who's calling?
-This is Aidy Bryant.
-Oh, then, no.
[ Clicks, dial tone ]
-Where the [bleep]
is that clock?
-What clock?
-Who are you?
-Your husband.
-[ Gasps ]
-Oh, man, I really do love
my new family.
I've always wanted to have,
like,
a famous sister
and a famous mom.
-Oh, Kim,
you're being so funny today.
-And these drinks you made --
what are they called again?
-Milkshakes. Yeah.
So, basically,
it's like ice cream in a cup
that you can drink with a meal,
like a burger or whateva.
-[ Chuckling ]
Love you, girl.
-Hey, um, is there any cash
that's just, like, around,
maybe I could, like, have?
-I have some cash right here.
What do you need, honey?
-Oh, Mom!
-I need my life back.
Where's that clock?
-Who is this?
-Ew! I don't know.
Um, but you have to go.
There's no clocks in here.
-I know it's here.
Give it to me.
-Go back to Arizona,
you stupid lizard trash.
-Do you mean this clock?
♪♪
-[ Shouts in slow-motion ]
[ Energy crackling ]
[ Thunder rumbles ]
-Thank God
I'm back to being Kim.
-Good. You know what?
I knew something was off.
-Totally agree, my daughters.
Hey, let's get this bitch out.
-I'm not Aidy.
It's me. It's Mom.
I'm Kris.
-Yeah, they all say that.
Send her to jail!
-What? No.
It's --
No, you've got the wrong girl.
-Thanks, Mom.
Oh, I can't believe
I slept with Aidy's husband.
-What? Damn.
[ Cheers and applause ]